I have one bone to pick with you which
is in the book I open the book and I'm
slipping through it cuz we're friends we
know each other well and I'm like oh
Joel's got a book this is great and you
were kind enough to send me a copy and
I'm flipping through it and I see a
photograph and the photograph says this
is a picture of me playing Conan O'Brien
as a child in a play and you look at the
picture there it is that is the most
offensive Irish character I have seen
and I've seen them all oh how dare you I
mean when I looked in the mirror as that
character I was like yes I will be a
late-night talk-show host how old are
you there and what do you what do you
really dressed up 36 there I think I'm
about 12 and that way I was the greeter
at my Catholic Church's annual auction
it was very racist leprechaun it was
like luck of the Irish give us money
the Catholics man yeah and my parents
were very proud that was the beginning
of my performing career yeah sure if I
did Troilus and Cressida right after
that wearing the same outfit yeah was it
wasn't necessarily a strict depiction of
how Shakespeare would have done it but
it was very close yeah there's yeah
you'll there's other pictures of you at
the end of the book we'll get to that
you know what I really loved no racing I
know there's no love lost between you
and Chevy Chase oh yeah well I try I
worked with legendary Chevy Chase for
five years and we would physically fight
each other and you have this one part
that I really love how to handle HIV
chase attack yeah
yeah it's really funny it's helpful yeah
I love her
you